cottage pie like cottage cheese like a
kind of shepherd's pie like is
shepherd's pie guys I'm from New York we
don't eat this we eat pasta and pizza
and bagels I mean it smells kind of
good I like that what is this um layer
of white thing on top is that potato
mashed potato that's not mashed potato
that is not mashed
potato oh wow this is a very serious
pizza with some very crusty pepperonis
it looks like a colony or a growth of
some sort underneath this cheese I think
this is like an American Pizza Rice this
is not American what are you talking
about oh I hate that I think Youk wins
but that's because you guys got a bad
Pizza